she's just off and her brother is I I'm
in love with her brother her brother is
like a scientist and he believes in like
the singularity movement and there's a
war and nevertheless doesn't happen hmm
you know we talked about that and he's
like trying to figure out ways in
college I think this is his job he's a
professor or something finding out way
is that how we can put a default in
these in technology so that we can turn
these robots off when there's inevitably
a war between us and the robots that we
create Skynet type of situation yeah
because that's it inevitably what's
gonna happen if you don't know what
singularity is I don't know if we talked
about it yeah this is that is the day
when machine have this consciousness
when they awaken and there's a lot of
people in the technology field believe
that it's gonna happen in the next
twenty five thirty years because now you
can track technology of how fast we grow
and we're growing so fast and we can now
predict what's gonna happen two three
four or five years ago
from now on like for instance years ago
I remember going to Disneyland and there
was a at Disneyland there's that in it
Tomorrowland tomorrow there's a section
called Tomorrowland is that the future
yeah the food yeah and then there's that
one thing where you go in it's like they
have like technology museum or whatever
and I remember them having a table where
you could like touch things and move
things around like like an iPad or an
iPod or whatever you have a touchscreen
but I remember doing it like we're never
gonna have this yeah and then literally
three or four years later it's on our
phone right it's like it's just gonna
it's gonna happen and inevitably we're
gonna have a war with them I like
hearing you talk about technology and
your turtleneck I was about to say it's
like a TED talk so yeah
are you could you ever do a TED talk and
if you do can you please wear that
turtle man what do you want me to talk
about on my TED Talks obvious that what
you just did will give me another topic
maybe I can do
I think I do talk about anything right
now with this [ __ ] turtleneck on
really good evening my name is dr. Bobby
Lee oh you added a doctor can I put down
you can see doctor you can't see doctor
if you're not a doctor
you can't know dr. Dre does it yes dr.
Dre a real doctor no well there you go
baby
I'm dr. B and tonight I want to talk
about comedy boo good night
if one boo if I get booed on a TED talk
okay I'll never do it again
[Music]